it doesn't matter if you're a wrestling
fan of a hipster a jock it doesn't
matter how you identify yourself
everybody has a good time that's lame
this is where they can completely let
loose they can yell fuck you they can
boo the hell out of the wrestlers they
hate and they can lose their minds for
the wrestlers that they love the energy
in that building you can feel it it's
thick
you know when I'm going upside-down
backflipping onto concrete that's real
can't buy that you can't write it you
know into a script I wanted to be a
ninja turtle and then I found out I
couldn't so I became a pro wrestler so
we're out here in West Oakland at the
victory warehouse this is where hood
slam all began this is the home of the
stoner brothers and they're inside doing
a training session so let's go inside
and check them off
what kind of training do the students go
through you're gonna learn how to fall a
bunch of times in a row you're gonna
have marks on your body you don't
usually get bruises in places you're not
used to eventually babies too if you
stick with it you learn to take pain
yeah you take this shit serious manly
ones our job if you're a first-timer at
a hood slam event what is it that you
should understand about hood slim for me
as a lifelong fan of pro wrestling I
want to take them aside and be like
whatever preconceived notions you have
about professional wrestling
forget all that at this point the
secret's out everybody knows pro
wrestling is a performance and not
genuine athletic competition hood slam
takes pro wrestling and puts it in
exactly the opposite direction and says
we're gonna make this as ridiculous as
we possibly can and you are not gonna be
able to help but come with us on this
ride we're kind of island of misfit toys
from a lot of the other companies where
people felt abused maybe they wrestle
other companies they don't feel
respected a lot of the guys that are on
our roster under sized nobody else
believed in them so I was able to get
them do that they were able to prove
that they can wrestle
you'll quickly walk us through a list of
some of the other wrestlers were
involved some of the crazy characters
that we have at Hood slam is the Mexican
werewolf El Chupacabra
he comes to the ring he's got fangs and
face pain and just this long hair and
drugs Bunny who is a 1920s gangster coke
addicted rabbit dark chic who is this
just dark and sinister brooding
character the hero of Hyrule link which
a lot of videogame fans will recognize
as the hero from The Legend of Zelda
we've got Johnny drink oh boo Toby and
Anthony boo Toby the Knights of the
Roxbury Marty mega man to be confused
with Marty McFly and then you've got
Virgil Flynn the third who's kind of the
anomaly of a lot of hood Slammers
because he doesn't really have an
over-the-top character we've got the
stoner brothers it's easy to throw this
term around but they're seriously one of
the baddest tag teams in the world
they've got their water boy Bobby burger
hands their cheerleader Missy hiya shit
their coach Joey nugs and together they
form a faction called stoner University
from Blountville smoke Lahoma some
serious wrestling going on
looks like it's in a high school gym but
the wrestling's good what's the
strangest place that you've wrestled so
people are eating around you and you're
the round so what is the $50 fan club
membership issue I'll show you why I
want to see this the fans get these oh
nice this is legit yeah Chupacabra makes
these mom makes these it's mom make them
for I gotta say the moms are pretty
involved what do you think it's a little
easier being a twin is that factor into
it it helps yeah plus the fact that I
don't know our mom's kind of off doing
her own thing she don't give a fuck
right like she's never even seen us
wrestle in 12 years not once do you want
her to come I do but she doesn't okay my
dad's gonna he actually helped like
right here this picture is my dad
actually right here he actually funded
for awhile and he was a character so he
embraced it from the begin yeah and then
he got out of it he's a born-again
Christian too so it's not really his
thing
doesn't find all that wholesome there's
a lot of stories in there tell us a
little bit about the genesis of GI bro I
returned the ring onstage in the ring
you're completely different sometimes
leave I'm talking to the same guy the
best wrestling characters take shreds of
the person's personality just amplify
them to an obnoxious level in this case
2,000% it oh just a gratuitous amounts
an endless amount
it's a very easy caricature of the
character to hate because I walk out
onstage I spray some Axe body spray on
myself Nickelback is my entrance music I
ripped my shirt off I'm jacked everybody
already knows fuck this guy and that's
exactly what I'm going for
I just take all these elements and I'm
just like nobody likes a fucking bro
I'd hate me hood slamet racks everybody
it's a 21 on over show so there are
people that are barely 21 and there are
people that are 6070 it's not your
typical like rowdy asshole arrogant
throwing elbows and fights breaking out
after match one broseph is going to talk
about how he's doing a match later
they're gonna leave the commentary table
and go prepare Josh who is on commentary
will be like oh this is like a good guy
thing to do I'll go help AJ enjoying the
match they've got their shit worked out
you guys beat dumb I drink oh into you I
love my grandma she come here support me
it means so much it's a throwback to the
wide-eyed mysticism of their youth when
they believed in Santa Claus and the
Easter Bunny and comic book characters
and we're taking an element of that
suspension of disbelief in Pro Wrestling
we're bringing that art form to them in
a way that is just kind of rough around
the edges and does not give a fuck that
was the attitude that gave birth to hood
slam it was about the fans we're not
doing this for the fans we're doing this
because it's fun for us if it's fun for
us it's fun for the fans